Raphaël Jacob bonsoir bonsoir Alexis
passage en revue de cette semaine en
politique américaine il y a des éléments
importants le premier élément évidemment
qu'on va à sa surprise aborder avec vous
ce soir c'est cette officialisation
disons-le comme ça de la candidature de
rente de santé sur primaire républicaine
où on sait les circonstances de cette
annonce sur Twitter en soit c'est une
histoire mais au-delà de ça qu'est-ce
qu'on doit retenir en fait je vais
commencer avec ça Alexis commençons avec
ça je savais pas si vous voulez d'entrer
de jeu commencer avec ça mais est-ce que
ça peut avoir un impact ça au minimum
dans le court terme la réponse est oui
et la preuve c'est que ne serait-ce que
par réflexe la première chose à laquelle
on pense lorsqu'on fait référence à
cette annonce là c'est pas tant le
contenu que le contenant est pas de
façon positive évidemment pour le
principal intéressé en fait je serais
tenté de vous dire Alexis pour les
principaux intéressés parce que c'est
pas seulement monsieur de santé c'est
plusieurs critiques qui vous dirait que
c'est encore peut-être davantage
monsieur masque mal paru exactement d'un
point de vue technique et là juste
rappeler aux gens qui qui sont peut-être
pas au fait de ces éléments là c'est que
le lancement de cette candidature s'est
fait l'intention c'était de le faire sur
Twitter en direct run De Santis ilon
musk mais quand tu es venu le moment de
débuter c'est là où rien ne se
produisait et ça a été là on a non
seulement ça a été long mais même quand
disons ça a commencé à fonctionner je le
mets en Guinée plusieurs moments on ne
sait même pas qui prenait la parole
parce que c'était loin d'être une
annonce de candidature traditionnelle la
plupart du temps on a le candidat
évidemment qui annonce sa candidature
donne un discours c'est la fin de
l'histoire là on avait une sorte de
dialogue semi-improvisé semi-scripté
entre une masque et d'autres
intervenants donc on avait droit à une
sorte de cafouillis à certains moments
c'était non seulement une orthodoxe mais
je pense profondément malhabile d'un
point de vue de stratégie de
communication politique et lorsqu'on
parle de l'impact vous savez quoi Alexis
j'ai repensé assez et le tout premier
discours on se parle de discours de
lancement de campagne le tout le tout
premier de pardon le tout premier
discours de lancement de campagne de
Donald Trump en 2015 rappelez-vous le
son fameux discours extrêmement
controversé il était
de l'ascenseur à Trump Tower il avait
parlé de son mur qui serait payé par le
Mexique etc
littéralement dans un discours fleuve de
peu près 45 minutes vous savez c'est
quoi la toute première flèche qu'il
avait envoyé à ce moment-là à ces rivaux
républicains c'était le fait qu'ils
avaient Barclay non pas sur le contenu
mais sur le contenant leur propre
déclaration de candidature avait même
mis à l'époque de certains candidats qui
avaient annoncé leurs candidature avant
lui et qui s'est adressé à des gens dans
les pièces ou l'art climatisé ne
fonctionnait pas et selon Donald Trump
on voyait ces gens-là et là je cite mot
pour mot transpirer comme des chiens et
seulement pour pour enchaîner après coup
et dire écoutez si ils sont pas capables
de gérer la climatisée dans une pièce où
ils font une annonce de candidature
comment croyez-vous qu'ils ont ils vont
pouvoir battre l'état islamique
maintenant on se dit ça évidemment le
réflexe pour bien des gens qui nous
entendent ça va être de dire quel
raccourci démagogique quand même
évidemment sauf qu'en même temps c'est
un raccourci qui est extrêmement simple
et simple à comprendre pour le simple
électeur et regarder à la vitesse à
laquelle à la fois Monsieur Trump et Joe
Biden le président démocrate sortant ce
sont je vous ai rué pour se moquer
monsieur de Santa justement sur la forme
de la politiquement c'était du bonbon
total les garder toujours ceci en tête
c'est sûr que Monsieur de synthèse était
connu largement avant son annonce de
cette semaine sauf quand même temps un
discours de lancement comme ça il y en a
pas 50 opportunité de la sœur dans une
campagne on a c'est vraiment la vie
c'est vraiment politique seulement une
chance de faire une bonne première
impression et là ça a été complètement
bâclé gardons aussi en tête ce salexi on
s'en parle beaucoup de ça parce que
Monsieur De Santis c'est dans une
situation où il doit essentiellement
faire un parcours parfait il est à peu
près 30 et pas et pas d'accessivement
loin 30-35 40 points en arrière derrière
de notre chambre et il est dans une
dynamique qui est particulièrement
difficile parce que puisqu'il est
deuxième il se fait attaquer à la fois
pardon au champ évidemment qui est
premier mais également simultanément par
tous les autres républicains qui sont
troisième quatrième cinquième et qui
veulent à leur tour devenir
l'alternative à Monsieur Trump
alternative principal et vous gardez à
vous ajouter à ça le fait que contenu de
ces relations assez difficiles avec les
médias traditionnels ces derniers s'en
sont eux aussi tenaient à cœur joie
suite à la débâcle de cette semaine sur
Twitter et en plus de ça évidemment vous
allez la Maison Blanche le cas démocrate
qui tire sur lui à bouleroes donc ça
fait beaucoup d'attaque encaissés d'un
côté quand on a de la misère à livrer
son message de l'autre mais qu'est-ce
qui peut faire la différence pour lui
qu'elle pourrait être la stratégie
miracle l'outil l'outil rhétorique ou de
stratégie politique qui pourrait
renverser la vapeur ou commencer à
opérer un changement c'est une bonne
question je dirais que Monsieur de
synthèse a peut-être deux avantages
majeurs que l'on occupe largement parce
qu'évidemment on est focalisé sur les
besvue les problèmes de sa campagne
dernièrement première avantage qui est
vraiment non négligeable c'est l'énorme
capital de sympathie dont il jouit
encore à ce jour auprès de l'électorat
républicains du réseau on posait la
question et ça ça fait à peine quelques
semaines à deux semaines au milieu du
mois de mai on posait la question
suivante aux électeurs républicains
l'échelle nationale la grandeur des
États-Unis quel lequel de ces candidats
potentiels parlant du côté républicain
seriez-vous prêt à appuyer
potentiellement de tous les candidats à
la fois ceux qui avaient déjà déclaré
leurs candidature et ceux qui
potentiellement allaient le faire
incluent monsieur De Santis le
gouverneur de la Floride était celui qui
obtenait le meilleur score et de loin
85% c'est même plus que de mon champ les
acteurs républicains se disent encore
ouvert à l'appuyer donc son plafond
potentiel d'appui demeure extrêmement
élevé il y a ça d'un côté l'autre aspect
également qui est non négligeable et qui
est très différent de notre système au
Canada c'est l'argent pour pouvoir mener
une campagne aussi longue et d'envergure
nationale ça vous prend énormément
d'argent c'est une condition qui est
insuffisante en soi pour gagner mais qui
est nécessaire monsieur de synthèse a de
l'argent les groupes qu'il appuient
comptent présentement sur une centaine
déjà de millions de dollars et d'avoir
suffisamment d'argent pour l'amener
jusqu'au bout de la ligne s'il devait
pouvoir se rendre jusqu'à là au niveau
politique au niveau électeur autrement
dit si ça candidature est encore assez
forte financièrement sa campagne devrait
l'être également donc ça je voudrais que
c'est un atout qui est non négligeable
et que ce n'est pas tout le monde du
côté républicain qui peut se vanter
d'avoir présentement ce statut de la
course donc moral de l'histoire malgré
un départ très difficile sur le plan de
l'image à tout le moins tout n'est pas
perdu Boré de santé on suivra ça de près
bien entendu Raphaël tout comme ensuite
prêt cette saga des négociations sur le
rehaussement du plafond de la dette on
aurait pu croire ça laisse régler plus
vite cette semaine mais là on parle
d'une entente imminente je pense que
tout le monde est rentré pour le
week-end ce sera peut-être un début de
semaine prochaine on en est où qu'est-ce
que vous savez qu'est-ce qu'on doit
savoir sur les dernières tractations
qu'est-ce que les républicains veulent
aller chercher beaucoup de questions en
une seule question à la connaissez
peut-être commencer toute la façon la
plus fondamentale où est-ce qu'on en est
à quel point assez imminent je dirais
que il faut faire attention là mais de
façon générale le meilleur signe qu'on a
quand tout au moins de part et d'autre
on sent qu'une entente et probablement
imminente c'est qu'on commence à avoir
les voix disons des gens les plus à
gauche au sein du parti démocrate et
celle des gens les plus à droite au sein
du parti républicain qui commence à
s'élever pour disons attaquer
l'éventuelle plan éventuel entente en
disant d'un côté on fait trop de
concessions de l'autre côté on en
obtient pas assez pourquoi est-ce que
c'est bon signe pour ceux qui souhaitent
voir une entente justement parce qu'au
final ça c'était clair d'emblée là pour
passer un plan qui va pouvoir être
adopté par les deux chambres du Congrès
ça va prendre un compromis qui va
rallier les membres je dirais plus
modéré des deux parties et qui va
exclure les membres dont les plus à
gauche d'un côté les plus à droite de
l'autre donc ça il y a ça comme
indication autre indication possible je
dirais c'est dans les propos à la fois
de Monsieur Biden de Madame yerlin ça
secrétaire au Trésor et de certains
autres représentant l'administration
américaine qui exclu de façon définitive
ce recours disons novateur pour pas dire
assez controversé le 14e amendement là
aussi on rappelle rapidement l'idée
c'était de faire quelque chose en fait
que jamais été testé dans l'histoire
américaine c'est-à-dire invoquer cet
amendement qui date du 19e siècle pour
essayer de contourner le Congrès
américain et avoir le président des
États-Unis qui de toute façon
unilatéralement relèverait à le plafond
de la dette là ça c'est exclu pourquoi
est-ce qu'on l'exclut de un parce qu'on
se disait très probablement ça ne
passerait même pas la rampe des
tribunaux mais très probablement parce
qu'on se dit de toute façon on va finir
par s'entendre avec le Congrès donc je
voudrais soyons patients soyons prudents
mais effectivement je vous disais la
semaine dernière Alexis je vous présente
encore ce soir je serai surpris quand tu
finissent pas par s'entendre est-ce que
ça va être lundi mardi mercredi on verra
madame yalaine je boucle la boucle
là-dessus à mentionné dans les dernières
heures que selon elle la date disons la
plus solide qu'on pouvait mettre de
l'avant présentement comme échéancier
c'était le 5 juin donc ça nous donne
quoi à peu près grosso modo une dizaine
de jours est-ce que c'est couler dans le
béton probablement que non mais on
risque de s'entendre
on verra donc éventuellement pour les
concessions qui seront faites les les
gains que pourront obtenir dans ce
dossier si les républicains je voulais
qu'on regarde du temps quand même pour
parler d'une part de Henry questionner
il aura donc 100 ans ni le 27 mai 1923
en Allemagne c'est tout un personnage
qui a laissé une trace profonde dans la
politique étrangère américaine il faut
quand même rappeler ces fédéraux mais
les contreverses qui le suivent depuis
exact en fait on parle d'un Titan et on
accorde ça au passé alors que plusieurs
pourraient vous dire qu'il laisse encore
une marque parce qu'il est encore
jusqu'à un certain point vocal dans les
dossiers internationaux incluant la
crise évidemment qui se coulent
l'Ukraine depuis la dernière année
presque tragiquement maintenant année et
demi donc au niveau de ces de ces
grandes réalisations parce qu'il a été
secrétaire d'État l'équivalent si on
veut du diplôme en chef je pense que
c'est assez difficile de passer sous
silence le fait qu'il va avoir été un
accord de premier plan dans le
rapprochement qui était à la fois
extrêmement imprévisible imprévu et
extrêmement important entre les
Etats-Unis et la chaîne communiste de
Mao alors que le président Nexon avait
battu une énorme partie de sa carrière
avant d'être président sur son
opposition au communisme et à la chaîne
et ça je dirais que ça dicter en énorme
partie certains orientations les plus
importantes de la politique étrangère
américaine pour les non pas année mais
décennies donc il y avait ça et la
volonté stratégique de séparer la Chine
de la Russie c'était personne il y a 50
ans on s'entend que ça allait encore
aujourd'hui donc ça comme héritage assez
incontournable du côté peut-être plus
controversé là aussi disons que la liste
est assez longue mais rappelons disons
la propension pour le gouvernement
américain d'être intervenu de façon
assez controversée merci surtout à cette
période là de l'histoire d'un certain
pays notamment le Chili au milieu des
années 70 le renversement évidemment du
gouvernement de l'époque de façon assez
brutale merci et qui a donné lieu à un
des dictatures probablement les plus
brutales de l'Amérique latine de la fin
du 20e siècle le régime évidemment de
Monsieur Pinochet sans compter les
bombardements illégaux du Cambodge
pendant la guerre du Vietnam est-ce que
Monsieur en était uniquement responsable
évidemment non mais là aussi va avoir
été un acteur peut-être plus tristement
de premier plan les historiens vont en
débattre et épiloguer là-dessus pendant
des décennies à venir ça c'est sûr et
certain en terminant quelques mots
qu'est-ce qu'on doit voir dans la
condamnation à 18 ans de prison du
fondateur des hautes skippers une un des
un des regroupements d'extrême droite et
qui sont intervenus dans le Capitole le
6 janvier en 2021 la toute première
chose à retenir à l'excès extrêmement
élémentaire je crois qu'elle mérite
d'être répétée continuellement on a
condamne pas à 18 ans de prison pour
sédition séditions les plus graves aux
États-Unis quelqu'un qui a été un simple
instigateur dans une énorme qui a mal
viré c'était une tentative de coup
d'état oui évidemment heureusement
quelqu'un qui a échoué mais qui est
quand même été tenté ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que lorsqu'on lit on entend ce qui s'est
dit au tribunal au moment de la
condamnation de ces deux d'extrême
droite là il y a quelque chose qui donne
assez je voudrais quand même assez froid
dans le dos parce que d'un côté le jeu
la cérémonie en disant carrément et là
je cite le jeu en question presque mot
pour mot vous représentez une menace
intégrale à la fabrique de notre
démocratie à la fibre la fabrique la
République américaine et le condamné
aurait rétorqué que son seul crime ça
avait été de s'opposer à des gens qui
veulent détruire son pays la morale de
l'histoire de l'histoire attend sociale
avec si lorsqu'on est dans un système
qui est aussi polarisé que celui qu'on a
aux États-Unis ça devient de plus en
plus difficile pour le côté perdant
d'accepter la défaite parce qu'il voit
le côté adverse non seulement justement
comme un adversaire mais comme une
menace existentielle pour ses valeurs et
son pays donc
on a ça à garder en tête et je conclurai
peut-être là dessus on se parle d'une
sentence d'une peine de 18 ans mais
qu'on parle d'une peine de 18 mois de 18
ans ou 280 ans garder en tête que si
dans notre chambre et réel en 2024 il y
a très très fort à parier que des types
comme ça vont se voir gracier plutôt que
tard et Erwan de santé se dit la même
chose pas plus tard qu'hier il serait
prêt à les gracier une fois élu alors
voilà à quel enseigne ces deux-là là
merci beaucoup Raphaël Jacob encore une
fois on vous souhaite une belle fin de
semaine prochaine